we love shooting this video series of
Jesse Hall farmer out of Arlington and
one of the things I want you to pay
attention to is how he has changed over
the years not on his operation but his
mindset I'm gonna get out of the way and
this way Osito hello I'm Jesse Hall and
I'm farming over in eastern Kingsbury
County I currently live on my woman my
mother his dad's place where she grew up
years and years ago I started farming
back in about 1996 dad gave up about 20
acres of land that was kind of my start
and I him and I had been farming
together you know pretty much ever since
til he's passing here about a year ago
and dad's basically the one that got our
family started no-tilling here back in
1988 he was friends with dr. Dwayne Beck
and doing at the time was telling dad
about this new idea of no-till and we
were having some problems with soil
erosion at the time we wanted to address
and that was kind of what we did on the
wet years particularly you know we would
really really struggle with wet spots
you know and and we were being basically
a corn soybean rotation and occasionally
we'd throw in a note or a winter wheat
or something like that but it's
predominantly corn soybean so what we
did is we would get the chisel plow out
and we chose a plow all the low areas
out and then we teal kolevatov the
spring and we thought well you've got
all these wet spots so this will fix it
well you'd get in and you plant it and
then then you only would flood out on
you again and it never did us any good
so then we decide okay we're we're gonna
try a rotary hoe so we go out and we'd
rotary hoe the fields in all these wet
spots and basically that dried it out
that that worked a little better but
then that planet every we'd see that
there was on top of the ground and then
you had a mess well in about 2000
probably 13 or 14 we switched over to it
to a basically a permanent three-way or
rotation where we brought oats back in
so so once we see once we started to
your our three-way rotation a lot of
those wet spots went away you know
there's a lot of there's a few areas
maybe acre patches or so here and there
that were there were always borderline
planning I mean you'd go through with
good conditions and you kind of slop
through that
those low spots and you'd get to the
other end and then those little spots
never really recovered a lot of those
spots went away you know I take home
messages you got to give stuff time and
if you're currently not a no teller the
big thing that you want to do is don't
switch the whole farm over to no tea all
all in one year just go field by field
let it be a progressive thing but if you
bring in small grain and start cover
cropping you're going to get your soil
structure much faster and you're going
to start seeing your soil turning around
much faster and if you bring livestock
and cover crops into it it's just going
to accelerate that whole process even
more so so instead of being three to
five years you might you might start
seeing a difference maybe sooner than
that a lot of people don't think they
can make any money on small drain and I
disagree you know you might have to
market a little harder and you can do it
but the one thing you have to take into
consideration is the yield bump you get
on the other two years
[Music]
you